[Music]
hi I'm Neil Mueller on the geographic
expansion team we build the technical
infrastructure that powers Google and
Google cloud platform this includes new
regions points of presence solar and
wind farms and terrestrial and submarine
cable networks today I'm here to tell
you about our new amazing region in
Singapore it just opened the Singapore
region was built to service Southeast
Asia which includes Vietnam Thailand
Indonesia Philippines Malaysia and of
course Singapore itself this isn't our
first region in Asia we also have Taiwan
and Tokyo our global network connects
all of our regions together all over the
world and our hundred points of presence
together this global network is the
largest network of any public cloud
provider now that I've told you about
the network let's talk about the
Singapore region itself for the first
time ever
TCP users can process and store data in
Singapore and as you can see from this
list the services include compute big
data storage and networking you can find
a whole lot more detail at cloud
google.com slash about slash locations
in short the new Singapore region has
everything that you need to build and
scale and now let's hear a few words
from our local team in Singapore to
learn what this new region means for
local customers hi I'm Aneesh I helped
customers migrate to Google cloud in
Southeast Asia
we've seen a huge demand for TCP
customers like Karis old coach at BBN
and PwC to name a few I'm not working
with Coach ecru using Google cloud
infrastructure services to run their
hyperlocal transport service in
Indonesia I also love working with
Council for using bigquery to power the
classified ad business used by more than
half the people in Singapore the new
Singapore region means speed of
performance testing of the Singapore
region shows sixty to ninety eight
percent reduction in latency when
serving customers in Southeast Asia has
come taken any other GCP region in Asia
with the opening of our Singapore region
Google is your neighbor right here right
next door
that's right and as you just heard
there's never been a better time to get
up and running with Google cloud
platform in Southeast Asia we think GCP
is the smart secure cloud that will move
your business forward and with our new
region and Singapore over right next
door we're excited to see what you'll
build on top of the Singapore region and
remember to check out the Google cloud
home page for upcoming summits that are
near you